foreign
[Music]
if evil is the same as goodness then
evil is just not evil nor goodness good
on the contrary both are suspended
moments evil in general is self-centered
being for self and goodness is what is
simple and without itself
when thus expressed in terms of their
notion their Unity is at once evident
for self-centered being for self is
simple knowing and simple being that
lacks itself is equally pure
self-centered being for self
if therefore it must be said that
according to this their notion good and
evil insofar as they are not good and
evil are the same it must also no less
emphatically be asserted that they are
not the same but are utterly different
for simple being for self or pure
knowing too is each in its own self
equally pure negativity or absolute
difference
the hole is only complete when the two
propositions are made together and when
the first is asserted and maintained it
must be countered by clinging to the
other with Invincible stubbornness since
both are equally right they are both
equally wrong and the mistake consists
in taking such abstract forms as the
same and not the same identity and
non-identity to be something true fixed
and actual and in resting on them
neither the one nor the other has truth
the truth is just their movement in
which simple sameness is an abstraction
and hence absolute difference but this
difference in itself is distinguished
from itself and is therefore
self-sameness this is precisely the case
with the self-sameness of the Divine
being in nature in general and human
nature in particular
the former is nature insofar as it is
not essential being and the latter is
divine according to its Essence but it
is Spirit in which the truth of these
two abstract sides is made explicit that
is by reducing them to suspended moments
and explication which cannot be
expressed by the judgment and the
lifeless is which forms its Coppola
similarly nature is nothing apart from
its Essence but this same nothing just
as much is it is an absolute abstraction
and thus pure thought or being within
self and with the moment of its
antithesis to the spiritual Unity it is
evil
the difficulty that is found in these
Notions stems solely from clinging to
the ears and forgetting the thinking of
the Notions in which the moments just as
much are as they are not are only the
movement which is Spirit
it is this spiritual Unity or the unity
in which the differences are present
only as moments or as suspended which
has become explicit for the
picture-thinking Consciousness in that
reconciliation spoken of above and since
this Unity is the universality of
self-consciousness self-consciousness
has ceased to think in pictures the
movement has returned into
self-consciousness
we pick up now with the second part of
paragraph 780 much too long to try to
compress the commentary into just half
an hour or so split into two sections
but we're going to pick it up at the
joining point between the two parts of
this I mean in in the English
translation two-page paragraph and so
Hegel says going back a little bit in
this picture thought there is depicted
the reconciliation of divine being with
its other in general and specifically
with the thought of it evil so we're
going to be looking at the possibility
of what reconciliation actually involves
and then he says if this reconciliation
is notionally expressed by saying that
it consists in the fact that evil is in
itself the same as goodness or again
that the Divine being is the same as
nature so we're going to come to that
Divine being in nature at the end so
it's very important that we realize that
there's a kind of mapping going on
between evil and goodness on the one
side and Divinity and nature and indeed
human nature or documentary because
right a little bit later on in this
paragraph that's going to get us to the
point of why this good and evil stuff
actually matters at this point
so he goes on and he says that you know
this is a unspiritual way of talking one
that's going to give rise to
misunderstandings or to an error or a
mistake an unrect as we're going to see
in just a little bit and then here's the
where we're actually picking up in terms
of the reading
if evil is the same as goodness then
evil is just not goodness nor goodness
good so what what does Hegel actually
saying there I mean first let's actually
look at the formulation if evil is the
same as goodness well not
precisely what the German says if evil
desposa
is so is the same
right so if it literally is the same
thing as the good which gives us now
three terms doesn't it we we don't have
a simple equal sign right like height
between evil and goodness instead it's
sort of like commutivity right if evil
is the same as what goodness is then the
two of them are the same that's what
hegel's actually saying here and so we
want to think about where does this
missing third term go and we're going to
see it you know coming back in sooner
than later and so he says following this
on the contrary both are suspended
moments now Miller is using this
suspended moments twice yeah I think
only twice in this and each time
suspended moments you know it's not a
very literal translation because what
he's saying there is that they are all
alcohol been so auf haibong right
this very complicated hegelian term that
has so much meaning and resonance and
plays a massive role within the
dialectical movement and building that
is what's happening to Good and Evil
that's also what's happening to Divine
uh being Divine you know Divinity as
such and to the world of nature which
includes us as human beings insofar as
we are natural beings right so these are
suspended moments good and evil
um and what does that mean well he goes
on and he says okay evil in general
is self-centered being for self goodness
is what is simple and without a self and
then he says when thus expressed in
terms of their notion their Unity is at
once evident so we're going to come back
to that in just a moment
what does it mean to talk about this
this Unity but first let's look at the
two sides
so
self-centered being for self once again
we see this in Zeke zayanda right uh
rather than anzique we have in Zeke so
self-centered is you know a fine
translation of that we we've had
previously going into the self right so
in the gay and and now we have furus the
exyne the first okay there's
Consciousness there or
self-consciousness an awareness
of oneself or of what one is doing
as evil now notice how he construes
goodness here goodness I mean we could
say well evil is more complicated than
just this by its very nature but the
good what is simple and without a self
zebs Loza einfachen right so that
einfaken is the simple zapsulosa no self
on the side of the good so being
selfless now we often talk about actions
as being good actions when they are not
primarily centered on the self there's
an entire tradition of this within
German idealism you know think about
Kant think about
um other thinkers we can even go back
further it doesn't just have to be a
German idealist thing it's a contrast
between egoism and altruism in the uh
British and the Continental writers
prior to Kant as well this is kind of a
framework right
but to lack a self and we've seen this
in back in the morality section
to be selfless because you don't
actually have a self is not to be
selfless in any sort of
deliberate or decisional or committed
way it's just doing what you do right in
a certain way we could say that
um
are very
rudimentary artificial intelligences of
the present our self Less in that they
aren't programmed to be
self-conscious to take awareness of
their environment or damage that can can
happen to them to have
um emotional comportments or anything
along those lines that are self-focused
or self-regarding right so if goodness
is that of course it's not goodness I
mean it's just business you could say
right and if that's going to be
contrasted to evil if goodness
disappears then maybe evil disappears as
well
so he goes on and he says when we
express them in terms of their notion
and here we have to be careful right so
Express right according to their notion
well
right so
could be plural uh according to their no
shuns or it could be according to their
notion when these are expressed
according to their notion Hegel says
then their Unity is at once self-evident
um
why
self-centered being for self is simple
knowing okay so that's another thing
that we can say about this
knowing not just in a purely theoretical
sense but also like knowing what one is
so you know knowing that one is evil or
bad or you know being too self-centered
focusing only on one's own needs and
wants and ideas as opposed to the larger
whole
so we've got one thing there and then he
says simple being that lacks a self now
this is where it gets really quite
interesting right simple being that
lacks itself is
equally
pure self-centered being for self
so it's the same thing as what evil is
well how's that the case
we could imagine a couple things Hegel
doesn't spell this out here but we could
think about this as being a pretense and
so the
person who is being completely selfless
is really doing so because they get
something out of it themselves so it
really is just another modality of being
self-centered in Ziona and being for
self right
or it could be that both of these are
just sort of mechanistic responses to
how things go on every entity attempting
to preserve its be this is actually an
interesting place to consider somebody
who hails not talking about here but a
lot of people who are into Hegel are big
fans of and that Spinoza I mean if
Spinoza is actually right and I don't
think that he is
um in a certain way there isn't any evil
and there isn't any good
right there's only our imaginations of
that and every mode complex mode that is
a human being
is a self-centered being for self in
this way but in a trivial way because
it's not substance it's not what really
matters
so put that digression aside from let's
come back to this
he says that if therefore it must be
said that according to their notion so
um
right according to their notion good and
evil insofar as they are not good and
evil
are the same and here's where we start
getting into some
what we could call depiction of notional
thinking this is a very very important
section of the phenomenology I mean
could have it could Hagel have told us
about this earlier yes I I think that
would have been helpful but he has in
various ways talked about this earlier
so according to their notion they are
the same DA salba they are also not the
same Nick Das Elba right and that means
that they are different
fishiden or you could say like
separated set aside right they are
distinct is another way of translating
it so they are both the same and not the
same
but utterly different
and then he says for simple being for
self
or pure knowing to
is each in its own self so now we're
getting to see something on both sides
what's really there not just how we have
been let me let the cat on the bank not
just how we've been representing it
right presenting it to ourselves
thinking it through representation
through four stellen that's an
inadequate way of grasping these
dialectical matters according to Hegel
but if we really think it through we
realize that on both sides the evil and
the good
what we actually have is pure negativity
Aina negativity right or absolute
difference
not just absolute difference between
them
within them
and then he says something else really
really interesting which again Miller
translates in a way that might be a
little bit misleading so what Miller
says is the hole is complete when to
prop is the two propositions are made
together and the German is yes
that's a propositions for London
best cancer so dusk answers the totality
the whole right that we are looking at
what uh you know if these are suspended
moments what are they suspended in what
are they suspended by that's that's what
we're asking here
the both of these propositions complete
the whole
so it's not just that the whole becomes
complete it's not that the whole is
complete if this happens to be the case
these two propositions being placed
together by something that exceeds both
of these propositions is what in this
case
fulfills brings to its fruition
completes perfects is another way of
translating it the whole the totality at
least this totality right we're not at
the ultimate totality yet but we're
getting closer
so he goes on and he says
um the hole is only complete when the
two propositions are made together when
the first is asserted and maintained
what is the first that these are the
same right when the first is asserted
and maintained it must be countered by
clinging to the other with Invincible
stubbornness usually stubbornness is not
a good thing you know obstinacy right in
this case that's exactly what we need to
do we need to cling to both of these and
say we're not going to just because
we're happy with saying that they're the
same we're going to forget about them
being different or if we're going to
insist on the difference we're not going
to lose sight of the sameness we need to
think both at the same time
representational thinking is not really
adequate to that it wants us to go one
way or the other this is what in other
places for example hegel's lectures on
the philosophy of religion
he will call a philosophy of the
understanding of the fishtand as opposed
to
dialectical or conceptual or however you
want to put it philosophy that he's
actually aiming at and so previous
philosophies have generally got this
wrong and then he says since both are
equally right fact right they both have
rightness they are both equally wrong
and then he says the mistake now the
mistake is itself unreact right so it's
not as if there's right and wrong and
then there's a third thing over them
that's a mistake of not grasping this no
the wrongness of which we might
attribute to either of the one-sided
things right the propositions in this
case of equality or or difference or
sameness and difference
um we are making a an you know a
wrongness a unrecht right an unrightness
that's what a mistake here is so that's
more than just like oops I made a little
mistake or I spilled some coffee or
something no you're getting things
fundamentally wrong in doing this
leading you in the wrong way so he says
what is this mistake
taking such abstract forms and here he
gives us two sets of examples what are
the abstract forms taking same not same
or same indifferent or identity and
non-identity
as being what something at fast
something true virus something fixed
Festus something actual Vehicles these
are the things that we're trying to seek
out through philosophy I mean hegelian
philosophy let's pause on this for a
moment I like that these are kind of
connected with each other because
um one of the things that we see
throughout the dialectic you know we've
seen this term vehicle cut coming up
over and over and over again Hagel is
interested in reality actuality vehicle
kite right an idea is true it Finds Its
truth it's it's the height it's you know
it's condition of being VAR when it is
made actual and when you do that you
generally find out that it's kind of
true and kind of false
it's more complicated right you
understand that conceptually fixed now
this is another really interesting point
right you it is tempting to say well you
know for Hegel nothing is ever fixed and
that's kind of true but things are
definitely
fixed within the scope of the dialectic
and in history for a while aren't they
otherwise I mean it would be pure
heraclitian flux or as James says
booming buzzing confusion you couldn't
work with that there has to be something
that we actually do take as fixed as
true as actual even if we're mistakenly
doing so for the time being and that's
that's what we do through four Stallone
through representation which by the way
is not garbage is not bad is not awful
hegel's not saying throw it all away
proceed on to some mystical intuitive
Insight no no hagel's not for that sort
of thing at all
he wants something that is sort of like
you know for stellen without its uh
lacks and impediments that is what the
concept is
something you could actually to explain
to another person so
the mistake is taking these abstractions
as if they are true fixed and actual and
then he says and so the mistake is
two-sided it's a you could call it
docsastic or theoretical mistake and
then there's a practical side to it
resting on them
to rest
to rely upon you could say as if they
are the the way things genuinely are and
so he says neither the one nor the other
has truth and what he means by that is
not that they are completely false that
would be going to The Other Extreme
rather he says the truth is just their
movement in which simple sameness is an
abstraction and hence the absolute
difference but this
as difference in itself is distinguished
from itself and therefore self-sameness
so we've got self-sameness absolute
difference and these somehow have to be
brought together in a complex Dynamic
way
and so he says
now here's where we get to as I
mentioned Divine being
this is precisely the case with the
self-sameness of the Divine being and
nature in general
and human nature that's mention in
particular
so he says the former is nature what's
the former Divine being the former is
nature insofar as it is not
essential being so God you know goes out
into nature God doesn't just create
Chaffin nature but God is in a certain
sense within the totality of the world
that we can experience including the
world that in involves us
you know it's worth pausing here for a
moment too to say for Hegel you know go
back think all the way back to the
self-consciousness section in the
beginning and the discussion of of life
for Hegel
human beings being in the world
makes the world a different world it's
no longer just nature it is the domain
of humanized nature right which is
a nature that can actually grasp the
Divine whether the Divine is something
merely projected on our part or
something that's outside of there
outside of the sphere of Nature and
Transcendent to it or a third thing that
we're aiming at and going to reach uh in
just a few paragraphs
so he says um the former is nature
insofar as it's not essential being the
latter what is the latter uh nature and
human nature is divine according to its
Essence it's vason right uh what is
important about it
so
Human Being Human Being within the
natural world is something
that is already essential and
the same as the Divine in certain ways
this again let's think back to all the
other previous religion sections right
the natural religion and then the
religion uh that's connected with
artistic production and reception and
drama and all that
that's what hagel's talking about here
we have we can read this backwards
um injected all of that into the the
world of nature as human beings without
realizing that we were doing so because
this is the development of Consciousness
so again he goes uh and he says
it is Spirit in which the truth of these
two abstract sides is made explicit by
reducing them to suspended moments once
again uh suspended moments alcohol
business by engaging in alphabum right
by surpassing them by transcending them
by canceling but keeping parts of them
and he says an explication which cannot
be expressed by the Judgment the utile
right and by these spiritless is the
lifeless is which forms its Coppola
right
um
so this is quite important here he says
similarly nature is nothing apart from
its existence but the same nothing just
as much is it is an absolute abstraction
and thus pure thought or being within
self and with a moment of its antithesis
to the spiritual Unity it is
evil right and now notice what he says
after this
the difficulty that's found in these
Notions
stems solely from what
clinging to the ears clinging to a
inadequate way of making sense out of
being and the being that we are that can
grasp that being sounds kind of
heidgarian doesn't it hagel's doing this
first
because of this temptation of reducing
the concept the notion to force de lung
to representation and to the copula to
the is statements to you know identity
statements and predication and stuff
like that this is where we lose sight of
things that he says there's a forgetting
that takes place here he says forgetting
the thinking of the Notions
in which the moments just as much are as
they are not we need to think both and
right we need to think identity and
non-identity we need to think sameness
and difference we need to essentially do
philosophical thinking I mean this is
the stuff about sameness and and
difference
uh this is not invented by Hegel this
goes all the way back to uh the time of
Plato and actually even before that but
think about Plato's sophist right where
he's exploring these thoughts uh in in
you know considerable dialectic this is
a very important for us especially if we
want to understand the Divine and our
connection to it so he goes on and he
says
um
forgetting the thinking of the Notions
in which the moments just as much are as
they are not are only the movement which
is Spirit it is this spiritual Unity or
the unity in which the differences are
present only as moments or are suspended
which has become explicit
for the picture thinking Consciousness
in that reconciliation spoken of above
and since this Unity is the universality
of self-consciousness self-consciousness
has ceased to think in pictures so it
was doing right and it was thinking
through foreshadowing representation
picture thinking and now it is realized
within that sphere the inadequacy of
picture thinking that's not going to
work for it anymore right and how is it
going to proceed now he says the
movement has returned into
self-consciousness
right
what is that going to look like well
we'll see in the paragraph that follows
there's going to be
something it's actually not not
something completely new it's been
brought up before
but something new that is now becoming
let's say
clear and evident to those of us who've
been following along the path of the
dialectic and Faithfully thinking along
with Hegel as Consciousness develops
itself